We asked you guys on Instagram:
What are the things you have always been wondering about in table tennis?
In this video we will try to answer the
most asked questions.
Why do table tennis players always brush the area
near the net with their hands?
This is one of the most asked questions on our channel too
And the answer has two parts
When you play table tennis
It's very common that your hand sweats
because of all the time being in contact with the racket
So between the points
It's very usual that players go wipe the sweat off of the hand
and then continue playing
And the reason why the hand is often dried here
is that you don't want the playing area to be wet
The second part to this answer is that
drying the hand on the table
is also a mental thing for the player
So often before the serve or the receive
Players want to take a moment to refocus
before the next point
Why do table tennis rackets have a red and a black side?
This rule came in the 1980's
because people were using two different rubbers
but with the same colour
So when you twiddled the racket
opponent didn't know which one you were using
For example if you have a pimple on the other side
and a normal rubber on the other side
It's easier for the opponent to tell which you a using
if they are different colours
I don't know if there's any particular reason
why it's red and black
but I think it's mainly because
it's easy to see the difference
Why are there nearly no pimples and antis
in the higher classes?
This is a really hard questions
And that's why we asked the world's best material player Mattias Falck
what he thinks the reasons are
Hi, Mattias Falck here!
That's a hard questions to answer
I think in the men's side
I'm the only one who have short pimples of the top 200 in the world
In my opinion it would be good if there were more styles in the top levels too
To get more changes in the big matches
and the syles of the players
I think the ball is quite good for short pimples
It's hard and less spin than before
so it bounces quite high
For long pimples I don't know
Hopefully Pongfinity have some better answers than me
Take care!
So this is a question I have also wondered myself
It's very common for everybody
to start with a normal racket
and then you get better and better with the normal racket
And then when you have already achieved a certain level
You don't want to start from the beginning again
Because starting to play with something
else than an inverted normal rubber
Usually takes a lot of time, a lot of practice
And most people don't wanna take the extra time
so they just stick to the normal one
Why don't you just play short
when the opponent is far away?
So it might seem that
when the opponent is far away from the table
it would be easy to win the point
just by dropping it short
But making a good drop shot is a lot harder than it looks
If it's not short and low enough
it's easy for the opponent to
just come close to the table and win the point
But if you know how to do it well
and know when to use it
it can be a really good shot!
Can you move the table by accident during a point?
So for obvious reasons it's not allowed
to move the table during a rally
But it's not even allowed by accident
The official rules say that you lose a point
if you, or anything you wear or carry,
moves the playing surface
Is being left handed an advantage?
It's not a real advantage
but usually it's easier
to play against right handed players
This is simply because there are more right handed players
so you are more used to
practising and playing against them
Also when you play against left-handers
the sidespin comes in the opposite way
and you have to readjust the ball placement
So there is a small advantage
So if you can choose
I would recommend playing left handed
So for obvious reasons it's not allowed to move the table...
Too good!
Why are you Emil laughing all the time?
I know I'm quite funny but try to keep it together!
It was fun and interesting to go through
and answer your questions
So if you have more of them
just leave them in the comments below
and we might make another video like this
Until next time!